we have not been formally introduced
I'm Amy and honey your guardian angel I
was thinking about sort of classic shows
like the winch then I came up would be
like sort of the modern version of that
but I'm a dermatologist with my dad
never practice that we share holies
sunburn dad how many days were you lost
in the desert played a quick nine this
one Oh dad come on
we're dermatologists not cautionary
tales I think she wraps herself up and
clumsy magicians I use it no worries
accidents happen and I bump into this
woman and we have this weird moment of
connection I'll bet you're a very sweet
person dr. Allison how did you know my
name and then I'm a doctor have we met
it feels like it doesn't it's like we've
known each other all our lives like we
have a psychic spiritual connection this
crazy maybe a little psycho person
starts to sort of push her away into my
life but uh okay you keep showing up
everywhere and it's freaking me out
absolutely it is weird creme de menthe
I'm actually on my way back to the
office because it's 2:00 p.m. on a
Tuesday
she tries too hard she loves too hard
she's clumsy she's an alcoholic it's the
grand event honey it sneaks up on you
her consciousness is a little altered
sometimes dr. Allison it's me Amy from
the farmers market
I ran tapas is running into you really
random and then she just pops up
everywhere everywhere I go it's like a
coffee shop a bar I want you out of my
life seriously
I will get a restraining order my
uncle's a lawyer or uncle's a dentist
why do you know everything she's not a
typical guardian angel but are there
typical guardian angels have you ever
met one I don't even believe in it but
these things that she's telling me about
my life and the direction I'm going
actually start to happen and some things
start to come true Evan is cheating with
Jill kid I'm so sorry no funny what a
cherry up to know that there is a
taquito behind your ear
amy does have some powers Alison doesn't
believe them sometimes and sometimes
she's floor got your first period a Red
Lobster which is super irise she's
coming off a terrible relationship a guy
who cheated on her
my mother just died so she's kind of
adrift Amy wants to make Allison see how
fun it can be to be spontaneous you got
to go with your gut mark Kim follow the
voices in your head
said the woman claiming to be an angel
because who doesn't want a guardian
someone who's got your back no matter
what you know sort of like your own
private super champion I'm not done yet
good if you need me I live above my
sister's garage project don't you get
your tool set ready Brad as part of the
the fuller family that Jane Lynch's
character Amy has kind of invaded and
we're pretty sure she's the most insane
person around but she also might be
giving us all the right answers Amy's a
genius oh because one cute girl lives
here no I really think our lives are
getting better Brad is all in with Amy
and flirts with her I'll pay cash it'll
probably be all ones and no I'm not a
stripper bread jana whoever she is I'm
welcoming her into a life whereas my dad
and sister are very suspicious so I just
had to come off of me Papa Bear cousin's
character mark and Alison are kind of
buttoned up science types you're getting
the face of all the sisters now aren't
you I'm sorry
yeah or should I say you're welcome
sorry works Marth take on Amy is what
the hell is happening not good not
trusting if I had a guardian angel safe
for just one day I think I'd want that
guardian angel to do
for me is what Amy is doing for Allison
which is to show me how great and divine
I am and I would love to get a shot of
that from